so today i'm going to talk about
astro astronauts you know and every kid
statistically speaking almost 20 to 25
kids of the united states of america
wanted to be
an astronaut and that dream kind of got
a huge boost with this spacex
demo two creo mission and bob and doug
when they
finally successfully launched to the
international space station after almost
a decade from american soil
more and more kids wanted to become an
astronaut
but those missions were kind of like
short-term missions
and they spent some months aboard the
international space station
and that is not as much risky as
compared to
the long term space flights which is
slowly day by day becoming a reality
with the successful manufacturing and
testing of
sls and starship by spacex and nasa has
already announced the artemis mission
which is going to be launched by
2024 and to speak in terms of
astrophysics or aeronautics the pointy
end is up and the flaming end is
down so it looks more and more likely
that we
are actually going to moon and to mars
and we are going to stay so
the one of the major factors for these
missions are these
mars and habitats and moon bases and
more and more people are coming up with
these ideas but
uh these astronauts are not going to
stay
inside these bases forever they are
going to come out
explore and not only that but the space
flight the journey
itself entails a lot of problems
and in the past one or two months
we witnessed how space tourism is being
popularized more and more
and how general public can get access to
space tourism and they can fly to space
but it's not such a rosy experience
after all because
there are a lot of problems some of the
problems are very traditional and we
have been knowing them for
a long time like bone and muscle density
loss physical strain
fatigue and stuff but with the
advancements of
next generation technology and
bioinformatics we can now
also gain insights into other problems
like changes in the gut microbiome and
that in turn affects the health of the
astronauts because we know that gut
microbiota is
connected with a lot of physiological
aspects of
a person like the gut and brain access
then there's risk of cancer that
reproducts reproductive system issues
neurodegenerative diseases
immune response changes metabolism
problems and
many other problems which we are not yet
aware of
so standing at that point i
tried to locate some data sets that are
available freely
and publicly to everybody for a five
other studies so there are numerous
projects
and to be honest very few associated
papers
i have made and collected a few of them
and thought of some
possible projects like this one like the
zebrafish
transcriptome under simulated
microgravity this was one study done in
association with nasa
then there was another data available
with adobe
system took to space
in blue origins new shepherd and virgin
galactic's
spacecrafts so to study what happened to
these
plant samples under the space flight
conditions that is exposed to radiation
microgravity hypergravity
low pressure oxidative stresses and
everything so that would be something
interesting
then there's hepatic stellates cells
under various
types of gravity like 5g 1g simulated
microgravity this particular
data was generated at indian institute
of technology madras
so this is the mrna expression of dld
and mlt
human cancer cell lines under
microgravity and they reported some
transcriptomic changes
again expression level changes
differential gene expressions and stuffs
and also there's one interesting study
which was done using the gut microbiota
and there the scientists found
very interesting patterns in the changes
in the gut microbiome
then they could actually differentiate
the difference
of this microbiota change pattern from a
radiation induced
change and a microgravity induced change
so
the authors suggest that there can be
very
significant patterns which we can notice
uh which the changes which are caused by
radiation and the ones that are caused
by microgravity
so these are some of the data sets that
i have collected and
one project that i have actually started
to
look at the data and hover around is
this one the zebrafish transcriptome
under simulated microgravity
so let's take a look at that this is the
particular
paper associated with it and they
actually studied this
positive feedback loop mechanism which
is actually a virus
induced immune response it involves trim
25
and rig 1 pathway and this
is actually done with the help of
interferon type 1 interferon 1 is very
important in this particular feedback
loop
and these zebrafish embryos were
cultured in you know standard gravity
and rotatory cell vessel which
actually mimic this microgravity
condition and then they were harvested
and their rna profiling was done and
stuffs
their survival rate was also looked at
and
there were two different types of
samples one sample was
which had no treatment and the other one
had the poly ic
vector treatment which is actually a
virus mimic and it
attaches itself with the two leg
receptor three
and it generates an immune response so
these are the two
conditions so in all we have four
conditions
so what they actually found was
the trim 25 which is a rig one regulator
and an interferon
stimulated gene actually had
a down regulation so this
is a very important candidate of this
positive feedback loop
uh that is triggered to antiviral immune
responses but due to the
microgravity simulated microgravity
conditions this was reduced
and since this was reduced the entire
feedback loop
was kind of hampered and that made
the cells more susceptible to the viral
infection
interestingly it was also found that
upon rescuing the
trim25 gene and not letting the
expression
fall the again the
feedback loop was unharmed and it was
saved from being hampered
so the cells maintained their antiviral
immune response capability so the
authors discussed there that this trim25
is a potential therapeutic target for
maintaining the
immune homeostasis under microgravity
for astronauts in the future and
till date there's no molecule agonist
identified
which can actually bind to the trim 25
protein
and they suggest that maybe admin
associated virus mediated crispr
activation that is a crispr a system
using a single guide rna could be a
potential solution which uh instead of
any small molecule drug or small
molecule agonist we can
actually use a crispr activation system
which can bind itself and activate the
expression level of trim 25
and thus you know keeping the workflow
going
so there's another interesting question
that comes up
which is how does microgravity affect
and why does these changes take place in
the first place so
again there are a few very interesting
hypothesis
and speculations like there are
three to five papers i guess in all
which suggest
that stimulated simulated microgravity
substantially affects the epigenetic
modifications
so to be precise they uh show the
scientists have observed epigenetic
changes in myogenic differentiation
process
embryonic development and t lymphocyte
regulation
also certain epigenetic processes like
dna methyl transfer s3 alpha
has been observed to be down regulated
in microgravity
and apart from that dna hypomethylation
h3 hypo acetylation and
certain mutational changes have been
observed
so the authors suggest that maybe this
down regulation
is a result of epigenetic changes
which they did not explore and they said
that it would be interesting to be
to see in the future so this is a data
set that we have as you can see there
are this
normal gravity samples three normal
gravity
and treated three simulated microgravity
three and untreated and
treated three so we have 12 samples in
all and
so this was a brief um analysis of the
data set
i did some pca analysis so the first
pc one versus pc2 has a
pretty strange uh variance 90 and three
but we can see that the normal gravity
both treated and untreated are forming
one particular cluster whereas simulated
microgravity treated
versus stimulated microgravity untreated
is not
forming a clear cluster and
upon doing a pc1 versus pc3 we see the
simulated microgravity ones are
clustering together whereas the non
microgravity normal gravity are far
apart and
pc2 versus pc3 gives a little variance
so they are all
not clustering together they are all
apart
there was one pathway enrichment
analysis which i did and
we can see there are four clusters and
especially in this one which is cluster
c we can see a strong
uh differential gene expression that is
the normal gravity
all the ones are upregulated and these
are down regulated so
i made a list so we can see some pretty
interesting
pathways like embryo development tissue
development
brain development and so on there's a
lot
which we can look into i also did a very
quick differential gene expression
and you can see these numbers
and this is the venn diagram also and
here i have uh
made a little point like a little chart
of
the down regulated pathways and
the up regulated pathways so again we
can see some interesting things like
protein transport
reproduction endoplasmic reticulum
stress
trna processing have been down regulated
am i transport
and under upper regulation we can see
gene expression rna metabolism nucleic
acid metabolism empire development and
so on
so such a exploratory
analysis kind of shows that yeah there
can be interesting
things to look into as well uh further
so what i feel
and what i want to pass on as a
concluding message is there are many
pathways
which are affected by a single space
flight
and space flight means all effects
combined we are only studying
microgravity in this one but
there are many other things which can
affect
and these studies are
really important if we actually want to
settle on any other planet
or explore them for a long duration like
for two years and stuff
because otherwise we are actually
risking the
people those who are going on this
particular mission because we don't
really know what's going to happen to
them
also such studies might help us explore
and understand some
pathways which we did not know about so
far or
to understand the already known pathway
is better like i have
one more example in the math kinase
pathway my kindness which is
pretty important for cancer uh
occurring occurrence is also affected by
uh
microgravity so that's one part which is
highly studied which is pretty much
established but
now we are studying under a different
condition and many different things
might unfold
so therefore that would be also
something interesting to look into
and finally i would suggest our this is
kind of my hypothesis that what can be
other ways in which microgravity affects
other than epigenetics
well there were two studies which really
made me think like this so the two ways
which i think is changes in protein
folding patterns
and that can cause some sort of
conformational changes and stuffs
and there could be changes in the cell
signaling pathways all together
and that was fostered because of these
two
experiments one was conducted by mark in
association with nasa so this is ketuta
is
one uh monoclonal antibody that's again
a protein
and you can see that it's formation and
it's
structure and the way it behaves
completely changes under microgravity as
compared to
normal gravity on earth so on earth it
really doesn't form
a uniform pattern it's chaotic whereas
under microgravity they
start forming a beautiful shape so
protein folding or
shape conformational shapes might be
affected by
microgravity that of proteins because
this is a monoclonal antibody
maybe this is one aspect this is a
kind of hidden experiment of mark so i
don't really have any associated paper
which
talks in detail about this and this is
again
the analysis of cancer cell lines under
microgravity so
when microgravity ceases to exist the
cell lines start rotating and once they
rotate they freely form 3d organoids
which are known as multicellular
spheroids so
without the application of any other
factor these
cell lines start to form this 3d
organized or speed up structure
but what's more interesting is they lose
their cell signaling
capabilities and once they lose the cell
signaling capabilities
the metastasis actually comes to a halt
metastasis has been seen to be stopped
because of
the intervention of microgravity so
again that kind of supports the idea
that there are certain cell signaling
changes which comes
into picture when microgravity hits them
all right so that's all i had for today
a really short
accumulation of my studies and ideas
and i would love to hear from you guys
what you have
to say about it